well four people joining this livestream
this is a continuation of a discussion
of a quite naughty subject of well
things like when does an entity exists
it's about in our new database
integration framework how should we deal
with the notion of entities that are
created on demand and so on so let's
let's take a look over here what we're
talking about so what we had talked
about previously let's take a read of
what this says right
and today extend okay so this is adding
for that entity class basically and
basically the question is what we should
put as the first step in the first
argument of the class should we put the
whole query or should we try to make the
very smaller can we just read what's
here first okay so do I have a hope okay
here we're going from the entity class
countries in the g8 which as you've
observed
change its character as different
countries enter and leave the g8 right
there was yeah there is part of the
problem yes right okay and what this
says what entity extend says I'm not
completely certain it's the right name
is for this entity class we are also we
are temporarily saying there is an
additional property effectively an
additional column in the table that is
called pop density and is computed like
this from this entity class where this X
ranges over all the members of that
entity class right I would slightly
phrase it different I think sometimes
entity classes can have their own
properties that are not present in the
poverties because it's a collection of
things this is extent the properties of
the members of the entity class okay
it might be a small thing but I think it
metals now are less important yeah in
the context of things that are backed by
SQL you should always have a guarantee
that things are rectangular some things
can be a separate table for an entity
class or something but but in this case
what else can be in the first argument
of entity extend other than an entity
class Oh a string entity I create by and
see drawing across and to de select and
he sort by anything heads that we were
discussing so it's anything that
synthesizes the table effectively yes
the net synthesizes the table by sub
casing the full country entity table by
filtering yes mm-hmm okay all right so
then now we're saying that now with
selecting an entity class here
oh boy this is the filter yeah this is
the Vista so II with that we are just
saying you know we synthetize this
population density which is a function I
was saying anything that is more than
5000 yeah but I don't understand why are
we not going back to the entity class
here and simply saying entities select
on that entity class of oh yeah we
absolutely could yeah okay so this
example isn't all that realistic cuz we
would not example that's what I wanted
to show with this example is that you
there are two filters here one is the
name filter g8 the other is a filter
that depends on an extension and you I
mean there is an algebraic way of sweep
them off both and I mean ricardo antonio
are arguing that should Larry deny
arguing that this might lead us some
into uncharted territory later okay hold
on hold on so are we seeing two
alternatives here if so what are they
the first alternative is that the
outermost filters can be removed whether
they are they are entity take and it is
sort by and the class or entity select
they are just the outermost one as far
as you're concerned this one I've just
highlighted that's what yeah but but
even the entity extend in this case
doesn't really change things and so you
can it actually commutes with the inside
and class and so you you could also
remove the inner entity class and just
get out basically something that is like
Italy with just the extension acted well
you're asking what should the result
from this entity list be should it be a
bunch of naked entities or should it be
something with a bunch of incrustation
exactly and the answer is there are
certainly some inc relation we all agree
that there are some in translation that
we can never remove leary that i are
saying well then let's not remove
anything that's the safest bet
and captain Tony are same but some
things are obviously removable okay wait
a minute wait a minute so what we've
agreed in the past is that entity value
is the evaluator it resolves things is
that correct yes subkeys event is value
right well we kind of agreed that entity
list would also be a resolver but the
question is but of what so the question
is are all other entities star functions
lazy
right because Enza d-class could in
principle you know unless early just
evaluate to a list of entities but it
doesn't entity class sits there lazily
so to speak right
right I mean the only thing that
evaluates is entity values for a second
think I mean there are also added
constructs that are evaluative but like
common name itself but like what value
or equivalently the entity sub value
evaluates well there are a couple other
seems like common name canonical name
yeah those kind of stuff okay so wait a
sec wizard so for example in the case of
common name would you expect that common
name implicitly calls entity value and
is therefore a resolver of everything
yes I think that maybe Tony can correct
me if I'm wrong so common name is just
an alias for retrieving the label
property fine
okay so but it does an entity value that
it it is like entity value of block on a
label yes okay let me ask you another
question so let's imagine that you're
gonna plot one of these things okay and
you've got this big lazy creature
lumbering along but now you want to plot
it you clearly can't plot the lazy
creature does plot implicitly call some
kind of entity value thing to resolve it
they I can plot Norwich property to
extract and which one irrelevant to be
plotted fair enough
okay so your claim is well I mean for
example feature space plot could in
principle feature space plot could take
I mean this may be exotic okay but it's
anyone say for future
explain I see you might have you go
ahead you have some of this annotated
clearance by but the end of the data our
country is inside and countries are the
only ones that we can de facto get some
outlines and plot them in the
Geographics if we stick in this
annotated decorated imputed entity class
we still want to see portly a picture so
somebody has to do the work and resolve
it right well okay so that's a question
of is there implicit resolution in
addition to explicit enter the value
style resolution right and what are the
cases where we need implicit resolution
in other words if you see one of these
things you either error out or is there
and that's the question so the the most
generic form of entity value I claim is
entity list
it's quite the contrary no but what I
mean by that is if you're given some you
know giant lazy creature right and you
feed it into cheerless plot then what
could gos plot - well it doesn't know
what what entity value to extract it's
not it's it's not done because Julie's
plot in the end even if you give it an
end to the least
polygon or something like that so well I
know but but it knows okay fine fair
enough
it knows given an entity it implicitly
goes and looks up the polygon of an
entity yeah so the the final thing that
actually doesn't need to go through and
to list at all and I hope it doesn't so
imagine you build up your own man TD
store with your administrative divisions
of Liechtenstein and and you just want
to create polygons once you don't want
to do it in two steps well okay so so
yeah but I also don't see how a without
seein I mean every every property that
they do not on the single entity are
also properties of the glass so okay I
just want to be clear I'm trying to find
examples I mean what you're basically
saying is you know entity value is in a
first approximation the only resolver
right yeah yes well but what is the
everything else resolver okay so that
then except with with special cases like
common name
and question mark enter the list is a
special case of entity value is that
true yes what is the actual what is the
version of entity value which is entity
list entities second element entities
actually entities is a special property
more correctly it would be canonical
name and you can guess the type from the
input entities so canonical name if that
is considered a property then entity
value can be used to result that I don't
know what I'm asking is if I look at
what is the identity if I look at entity
list of food right by the way I'm
generating in this version I am
generating a weird self test error
that
but up here that when I typed that
entity list
it must be an autocomplete soft test
error let me show it to you um somebody
should take a picture of that please
Dominic or somebody
cuz it cure okay that happened when I
typed to entity list um
you should feed that to the user
assistance folk it's a bug and whatever
I'm using here I don't know what version
I'm using okay let's find out
that's really strange
that's really strange okay so you should
okay so that happened when I typed an T
list for some reason I would I would
strongly suspect yeah oh wow that is a
repeatable bug oh look what it says look
what it says it says try file missing
from layout
okay so let me just all sanderson sigh
it's actually a high-priority nasty bug
so you're sending that out I guess I
will okay I don't really it needs to be
done now so um
you
you
you
you
okay
so that of tracking
system okay okay
in any case so tell me what is entity
list of food equivalent to entity of
entity type name of food so just a basic
version
now comma hash closing square bracket
and also it's the hash war hash and in
closing square bracket and percent and
then you map over
value of full comma canonical name so
that would be a basic version of a mod
you know what does that mean yes which
is the whole discussion I guess yes so
we are wondering how to extend that no
well enter the type name if it isn't if
it is a pop-up entity so to speak it's
not clear what that should be
yes exactly um okay okay let's see
you
ah all right so let's go back here
um
you
all right so what's the okay so we're
agreeing entity value and somewhat
entity list is the only resolver so
everything else is lazy it's a little
bit unfortunate that again III anything
that's lazy should be a noun
unfortunately entity value is also a
noun but entity extend shouldn't be that
as I've said before it should be entity
extension if it's anything am I making
sense yeah I mean again my point is
which doesn't really work for entity
extend or extension is that for many
others there is like very clear
correspondence with the meteor operator
like select it should be selection if
it's lazy link is not enter the
aggregation by if it's in Lisa what do I
mean what is that
well I don't know what is that yeah I
mean that's a okay we need noun forms
with these things by the way somebody's
making a weird background noise um
these I'm adding to
you
um okay so let's keep going over here so
what is the is there an alternative
that's being presented
what are you suggesting here
so what I'm trying to fish to strip
certain things like if you have filters
on the top level before aggregation or
if you have divide strip do you mean
make the non lazy no ring them from the
output type that is returned for the
entity of the first argument of twenty
least one entity count to g8 you get
entities with country as the first
argument you lose the fact that they
came from g8 yes I understand that's the
old discussion is whether Antilles tries
to resolve filters and move listen
listen listen look look look
entity value an entity list are
resolvers they should resolve whatever
they can resolve because in the end
they've got to get an answer I mean it
reminds me of the somehow I'm reminded
of the quixotic adventures of things
like Haskell at some moment in its life
when you know when the thing was so pure
and lazy that it never actually gave an
answer right in the end we've got to
actually get an answer we get an answer
and when we they get an answer they
should strip everything they can strip
because they're trying to just get an
answer now we may have other functions
that don't do that but we need some
function that just goes and gets an
answer but there is a problem with this
theorem and the problem is that part of
the answer remains lazy meaning that
entities themselves are lazy references
and it returns a list of those things
okay so so wait a second so you're
saying okay so case one you know most
operations quotes stay lazy
okay except for the resolvers okay so
now your issue is what happens when you
think you're using a resolver but you
can't actually resolve all the way yes
and the question is what do we resolve
okay okay what happens if you think
you're using a resolver
but full resolution isn't possible okay
full resolution okay so what I mean by
full resolution is it is computing
okay so resolution the claim would be
resolution is compute to return
non-entity constructs eg quantities or
base
I'm gonna make a claim here that may not
be correct okay or essentially or
resolved functions of base entities what
is a base entity base entities can
include non pop up entities from
external sources that will be my claim
for what resolution means yeah full
resolution we all agree I think that is
completely miscible if you look at the
two examples above you have to keep
entity extend because otherwise you
cannot compute properties and you need
to compute aggregation because that
changes like the algebra of what you're
looking at so basically the second
example these things behave like Europe
like continents they don't behave like
they don't behave like countries anymore
so you can't resolve that so in a
certain sense there are many cases where
you cannot fully resolve sorry could you
say it again I got too distracted here
okay so what I'm saying is that you for
example you cannot remove extensions
because otherwise you cannot access
properties anymore and you if you're
doing something like that changes the
algebra like aggregation joints you
cannot remove that because like look at
the second example those guys behave
like continents they don't behave like
countries anymore so you can't remove
aggregate by so again full resolution is
impossible even the partial resolution
okay hold on hold on what gets an answer
what are you gonna do with this thing
that you got here
for example you can request certain
properties from it the values okay
revolution that's the final resolution
so this thing is unresolved what do we
do argue the results or assume they're
sparkly resolved okay so wait a second
wait a second so what is the operator
that causes partial resolution is it
entity list or what it is the list yes
okay so okay so the claim would be okay
so can you have an entity value that is
not fully resolved
no okay you can transcend edges because
because some properties might be entity
valued so you can ask what is you think
Italy and you ask from the capital city
that returns a reference to Rome that's
not fully resolved well wait a second
what does that mean we said full
resolution can return either nonentity
construct or resolve functions of base
entities like a list of cities or
something okay then there is another
another example where it can happen
stone if you are doing entity list of an
aggregation then you resolve two
entities which are aggregate so they're
composite they are not based entities so
so imagine you're doing entity list of
the aggregate by of country over
continent of the country
oh I see it right yeah and in that case
you will return entities which are not
based entities might depend on some
enough it listen listen listen listen
you're confusing yourself again okay the
this is entity list doing its work again
right yes
but so special case of energy values you
can also ask Canada but what you're
saying is okay so what I'm saying is
something has to actually resolve the
thing right and you're saying that you
can be in a situation where it never
resolves
well what's returned is a bunch of pop
up entities yes no yeah the thing is
that entity sees a partial resolve by
definition when you have pop up and okay
okay hold on hold on hold on the first
question is is entity value always a
full resolver no okay so let's let's
understand okay so okay what is partial
resolution not why not why did you see
values not always a full resolver well
read the definition read the definition
here okay
resolution compute to return nonentity
constructs or resolve functions of base
entities no making sense yeah but if you
only know it's there that's the
definition that's the definition I want
to make a resolution okay - what resolve
function means there that's context okay
resolved okay okay
built-in functions let's say that
built-in functions are base entities
okay entity related non entity related
built-in functions okay so things like
list or squared or plus or whatever else
see what I'm saying what about them
because one thing we were thinking I
think not
that's what I'm saying that's what I'm
asking here so this is a straw
definition for a full resolution and it
says that that's not um okay no because
because we were thinking of some cases
in where where it might be useful to
return entity class from entity value
but let's not get into that now because
I think it's an instruction I'm sorry
what is the distraction okay so in some
cases like for example you imagine you
when you look at notable books by still
more from we currently return a list of
twenties but it might sometimes be
useful to say to return basically the
inverted entity class of book type so
say instead of there what are the
notable books might see you know from
the answer is and the class book author
goes to Steven Moore from sometimes it
might be useful to keep it that way but
especially if you're going to chain them
and ask for like publication dates of
those books more efficient if it's not
list well it may be more efficient but
I'm asking the question ok let's say for
now yes for now yes as thing stands now
the answer is entity value always
results but what about entity value
acting on this pop up entities on
returning some of them back as for
example ng to property association yeah
sure with entity property Association
but that's in the keys so you should not
worry about that by the central dogma of
Association okay so you only restricted
to argument energy value also that's a
modifier okay wait wait a second so that
okay
so let's ask the question then what does
partial resolution so full resolution do
we agree on the definition of full
resolution
well we can't agree or disagree you just
made the definition so we accept it okay
fine okay it's a definition okay fair
enough all right okay so do we then
agree that entity value always causes
full resolution
yeah probably I can't think right now
counterexample but okay alright so then
then we can write down entity value what
did I just do here well weird okay
entity value
oops causes full-resolution
um entity lists however may not cause
full resolution we don't yet know
that's a big question mark I think we
know and the resolution is impossible
but you've also so claimed that entity
list is a special case of entity value
so you can't have it always but the real
problem is the answers that name part
not not the answer yes yes yes okay fair
enough
and then we've also got entity type name
which is a weird concept that's some
where are we here okay so partial
resolution what does that mean that
means that you are getting back
essentially these lazy entity constructs
is that right
well yes okay yes is there a discussion
those lazy constructs do absolutely
nothing they just sit there right yes
and they sit there until entity value is
called well but this time on them
separately well what does that mean I
don't understand what you mean by that
there's there is an object that some
kind of giant encrusted entity aggregate
by entities select whatever and yeah so
that's one time type of that entity I
guess you know I guess that the question
is do we want partial partial resolution
because in some cases we can safely say
you know taken to the class country g8
well you can strip the fact that it was
coming from g8 and just return it but
then if you're like aggregating the
countries of g8 by continent
you cannot strip the fact that they were
coming from g8 anymore and so when I
don't know Egypt enters g8 then you have
a new entity there's Africa because it's
the continent of Egypt and that thing
exists or doesn't exist depending on the
belonging to g8
if the resolver has run there is no more
lazy stuff anymore in other words it's
just like if I do the following if I say
now you know today you know if I say day
of week what is it called week so it's
called it's a cold well anyway if I say
date value of today come a day of week
what it's called that's full resolution
and the fact that date value is not Auto
completing its second argument
and that's another bug
okay I didn't hear anybody say yes so
I'll do it myself we'll do it Stephen no
I'm doing it now
also the pop up there had the wrong font
I reported that as well okay um whatever
you get the point that you can say
ah yeah okay that you can obviously that
resolves right but it would resolve to
something different you know in a month
right yes
okay so similarly here there are things
like entity value that will just resolve
and whatever they resolved to is what
they resolved to now if you run them
again on the same raw expression they
may resolve to something different in
the future
am I making sense right yeah but at
least unfortunately is like okay list is
a weird intermediate case I'm just
trying to understand you know entity
value what you know how is that working
do you get what I'm saying so answer
date so what I'm saying is
apart from entity value in a first
approximation ignoring entity list
ignoring entity type name apart from
entity value everything stays
unevaluated is that a true statement
so in other words the the functions are
do you have a list of them somewhere and
today select entity aggregate
aggregation entity selection I think it
should be entity aggregation by
I think it is way too confusing to have
them not be nouns forget what I'm saying
fine then I'm just tell me what the noun
for joining is I don't know entity when
you join two things you get a mongrel
first and the mongrel entity joining or
something I don't know I don't know
that's not a very good name okay that's
a separate issue let's look at those
together okay but but this is I mean
I think if there is no non lazy form of
these functions now you know if they're
inside a wrapper that makes them lazy
and if there is an an eager immediate
form of them then certainly it can be
entity select you know if it is kept
lazy by something else but you're saying
that entity selection on its own is
already lazy it's born lazy so to speak
is that correct yes and it's not made
lazy by being inside a function or
something such other thing correct yes
it's completely in order by itself okay
okay so then what you're saying is okay
so
a value could entity value return
entities that contain laziness
well in some sense all entities to some
extent contain reasons it went on right
okay but so look at our definition of
resolution here nonentity related
built-in functions of base entities were
based on please conclude non pop up
entities from external sources mean by
that is it can be entity of source comma
name but it cannot be some deeply
encrusted implicit form so do we believe
that it is possible for entity value to
resolve down to nonentity functions of
things like this or are they irreducible
pieces of sort of lazy entity function
well there is there is one exception
which is basically if you put something
weird in the beta of your entity and
that thing is like an entity related
function with some stuff in it
then you're out of luck but on the other
so but on the other hand until value
should evaluate to the things that you
could say if you're a have a built if
you have sorry in memory entities entity
value let's say that the return value of
an entity store is a an encrusted lazy
entity construct you know what I'm
saying
the return value of an entity store the
property of an entity in NC store right
let's imagine that that is an encrusted
object okay that the thing you put in
there was just an entity aggregation by
blah blah blah blah blah right that that
is the the value that's returned oh yes
so it's as if so that thing might be in
the entity store right that would be a
thing where you say you know whatever it
is property blah blah blah aro value
here but that aro value is an encrusted
lazy entity construct get what I'm
saying yes okay now you are in the
process of extracting you extract that
value
oh I see I see so yeah okay so that
value
oh boy will not be resolved I don't
think you should resolve the value
because you might end up in a regression
error or okay but hold on hold on this
case where it's : greater than an empty
value that will resolve fine but the
other case there's nothing to resolve
because if you solve here then it's not
going to resolve you see what I'm saying
then there isn't enough information to
resolve it there's no entity value to
resolve it it's just some you know
random floating you know uh Nevada
density construct
make sense yes so that gives the counter
example to the statement that everything
resolves it means the definition has to
be more nuanced yes yeah you can say
basically that you end up having
something which is functions of the
values you put in everything hold on
everything that yes sir but what is put
in mean because there's different layers
are put in this right so I think what it
is is there is and there's also
different levels of entity Val units I
suspect that entity value peels down a
certain level of entity function
incrustation so to speak
appeal isn't just a resolve in the
robert is whatever the completion of the
property are returning yes but my point
here is is it the case so we've given an
example here where entity value does not
resolve all the way
well it does I mean in a sense it's if
you think about entity value like
function application is returning the
result of applying an entity function
that's it if the entity function is
returning again entity constant may be
right okay so fine so the the the
awkward case is entity type name aka and
the list
right so entity type name is of this
encrusted composite entity
tell me what is the type of entity that
this is right and the answer the
question is does that in any way resolve
I don't think it can and that's what we
also think was Karl okay so hold on so
what would entity type name I mean it's
a very weird
what does entity type to entity type is
it means that actual entity type is that
right now there is no entity type it's
just entity type name
in a way the reason this time soon
that's the first argument of entity but
still I think that there are for me
there are two possibilities of
simplification but it's like and I think
that there is a version of this thing in
in the code of the entity framework
there is like one version of entity type
name that recurse is recursively curses
and Indian tells me okay these are all
the base types involved this can be like
can contain city county and person and a
character list of things because not
necessarily one table is involved in the
operation and there is another thing
that doesn't resolve anything all right
I don't know you saying that entity type
name does today well that's say you're
saying that's what I see type name could
do but and you that name right now
doesn't really say anything I mean right
now if you pass it
yeah I'm right now element event today
yeah but if you if you pass it an entity
class it will remove the filter on the
other hand I would say the antitype
neighbour entity class returns entity
class okay so hold on hold on so if I
say entity class and the class of
country comma g8
why is that part of completing I don't
know that's weird
probably not correct well your the
question is is that correct
yeah that's exactly the question okay
and in general Karlin myself think that
in general it's wrong and so we should
keep the original construct whatever it
is as a type well auntie that name is
identity basically no because entity
type name listen when you're are the
base entity right if I do this whose
country should we pick let's do that
okay the when you're at a base entity it
is a trivial extractor of the first
argument of entity
is what does it do when that thing there
is not an entity class but it's some
kind of you know entities select and to
this selection and entity class that is
elect are the same thing
you think about it and since election I
even say you can write the renting class
as you know membership equals g8 a
filter isn't really changing the type is
it and a sorting operation isn't
relations in the type a take operation
is not really changing the type an
aberration that changes the type is
aggregation that that is changing the
type but depends on what the definition
of the type Ricardo yes another thing
that effectively changed the type is
entity extension the extension for sure
until joined for sure and but we can
argue that the filter and sorting and
other operation are not really changing
the type but you say that entity
selection at its base always operates on
entity classes is that true it doesn't
operate directly on an entity can it
operate an entity type well I would say
it operates on the classes yes okay what
happens if I want to do a selection from
all countries how do I do that well if
you can just use the string country
which is an alias for the class of all
countries I see so that's an alias for
entity class of country common yes okay
okay so entity extension is an example
of something which isn't going to so the
entity type name of an entity extension
better not get rid of the entity
extension because it's actually changed
it's effectively a pop up type exactly
yes okay and so we can't remove it yes
but what we try to argue as Carlos is
that also even for cases which seem to
be removable we better not do that yeah
I agree I think it's to be very well
defined whether you removal you don't
remove and my claim is that only entity
value removed
so now the question is what should
entity list do should entity list remove
as much as it can or should it not my
guess is that what should happen is that
entity list and this is probably where
we started actually that entity list
should remove as much as it can that
that's its best most courteous operation
okay so my claim would be that the only
things that remove anything are entity
value an entity list an entity type name
I would say entity type name should
simply fail for anything that isn't a
very plain Jane entity
but then I'm sorry but then so should
entity list if it's built off no no no
no no I'm saying Anthony list is not the
definition you gave at the list before
in terms of entity type name would no
longer be preserved that entity okay so
let's go through it
entity value does full resolution okay
every other entity operation doesn't do
any resolution at all
footnote except for common name and some
things like that that are basically the
same that aliases is an entity value
okay okay then the claim is that the
intermediate case that we're still
flapping around about this entity list
okay entity type name just fails unless
it's eating an entity with a very
obviously exposed type um an alternative
would be that entity type names simply
returns back the complex type it
encounters that's probably possible too
now does it always have an obvious type
I mean an S the attention but I mean if
we assume in my in maybe you if if we
decide I mean is not clear yet if we
need to if we are going to the road well
you know we strip out stuff or we don't
but if we do strip out things from entry
list then the same kind of resolution
should happen in an entity type name to
me okay let's let's look at okay so an
entity type name of an entity class
should that strip
I don't even understand what is the type
of an entity aggregation by it's just
that same integer aggregation why but
why is that the type that's the full
thing itself so there's an example that
made me understand that question
actually and it was let's say you start
for a user starts with an entity store
that has just some cities
doesn't have countries but the city
entities in his entity store have a
property called country now which gives
maybe some string country names or
whatever look then the user can group
his cities by country look
and then he needs a handle to this
country virtual types and that's why we
can't get rid of this group by country
comes to I understand that the point
that I'm making is it's one thing to
have an entity class full of actual
entities right but I claim that the type
of that the type of that sure isn't the
thing itself you see what I'm saying but
why no because because just like the
entity type name of the entity Italy
isn't the entity Italy its country yes
yes you're you're confusing the first
and second argument of entity what we're
talking about is the first argument
which I know we're talking about that
but I'm saying that in this entity
aggregate by the thing you have there if
I'm understanding correctly is the full
answer it's not just the first argument
of entity right I entered the
aggregation by is well let's let's take
entity selection okay enter this
selection of an entity class is a new
entity course right it is full entity
class full of entities full of countries
full of yes yes various forms of life
whatever it is okay yes it is not the
type of that the type of that is a
different thing the integer 17 is the
integer 17 it is not the type integer
right yes but it's a different example 7
because here you have a lazy construct
which like you say when you say that
entity selection is a
full answer full of entities but because
it's lazy it's at the same time I'm also
a type no no no it's an answer the type
of it is entity type of that another
lazy thing it's perfectly possible to
say that you say what's the entity type
of it okay it's entity type of that
because you know what lazy I was kind of
pointing out the same thing long ago and
was exactly on your position but then
Karl or convinced me that you don't
really have a difference between it's
not right it's not right there's two
levels I mean this is thing it's really
you can't decide what like think about I
don't know integers all the integers and
then he selects only even once yes I
know
no no no no wrong wrong analogy this the
results of the select is the set of even
integers okay this is this is what old
Bertrand Russell you know when he
originally invented the stupid idea of
types okay he did it in order to avoid
this you know the set of all sets and so
on right he he did it in order to have
another level that isn't the set itself
do you get what I'm saying
and that's what we need to do as well in
other words there's a difference between
the thing the set whatever and the type
of the set
you mean the barbers paradox yes
something like that
the real problem is that in relational
algebra there isn't really a difference
that's not and then it becomes even more
complicated because SQL doesn't really
implement the relational algebra and so
things are not set fine okay that's as
may be but for our purposes of
unscrambling this and being able to
generalize it we do need to recognize
that a thing is not the same as the type
of a thing okay so one question I would
have to use doing is because this thing
is lazy isn't that at the same time a
set like no no no all the the thing you
get out is a set right
you can perfectly well ask what is the
type of that set right that that set
which is a result has not been
materialized magnificent I agree okay no
will the sensitive type be realized this
will also stay lazily unev alyou ated
see what I'm saying so that becomes an
entity type name my proposal would be
entity type named simply fails unless
it's given a a bear base entity okay
just fails why cannot just return this
entity type oh it could yes it could
return the answer to type thing it could
do that it's a little weird I think
that's a corner case I will be happy to
have it fail if it doesn't given a base
entity type entity type name that is but
entity type should remain you know
entity type there should
I claim remain unavenged structure
inside okay and then mission would be
what causes entity typed and then once
you have that entity type among other
things you can feed it in as a type of
an entity here if you want to currently
sort of doing was the naked internals of
that right but I'm saying that and maybe
as a courtesy we can support that but
this is the full form of it
that it is the entity type of that and
there is a there's an algebra of what we
can do with the type and so for example
if we had entity type there and then at
some point we say common name of that
for example common name is a resolver
and so if that's resolvable which it may
not be that would resolve it no man they
call my name of an entity that should
come out with a product here is it if
it's not an entity it cannot really you
know no ok fair enough it comes out with
but ok but let's go back to what entity
so this is my claim that entity type
needs to exist it's the symbolic
representation of the type of a
potentially composite potentially lazy
entity structure ok ok that was my
suggestion a year ago but then somehow I
get convinced or a second ok
now there's entity list okay so entity
value again is a resolver so it tries to
resolve anything entity list what does
it do
right what is the most convenient thing
for entity list to do it certainly we
have certain end edge end cases one end
case is if you can resolve a zit list
should resolve if you cannot resolve do
you do partial resolution I would say
probably yes so in other words if it can
resolve all good you just you know you
just resolve to a list and so by partial
resolution you would mean that it will
obviously resolve primary keys for the
entities and also it will try to resolve
the type to them more simple form of
that side that's what I think I I
consider this a little bit heuristic
what its gonna do but I mean we have to
have a definition it's not certain I'm
not certain exactly what it should do
what I'm not willing to predict right
now is what is what the shape of the
heuristic is going to be as we have more
features that's fine that's why I think
but but color that just like practiced
or the safest bet right now is to not
try to be overly smart because it's I
have a feeling that is going to bite us
back when we try to support things like
window functions that's fine so my guess
is that entity list failing to resolve
or even giving errors is okay
I think that if Angelus doesn't give a
list it possibly should give an error
see what I'm saying for now but it's
much easier to back out of giving an
error than it is to back out of giving a
result that we don't think is the right
result
if it gives them nobody can build on it
okay no they actually can because they
can expect that in order to come and
whatever okay they can do okay people
can build on sand you know if you give
them a whatever but but but okay so what
I'm suggesting is that that the the
policy should be entity list is
basically merely a sort of heuristic
endpoint it is not the thing you use to
do serious to build up serious
programmatic stuff
what you build for serious programmatic
stuff is use entity value as the
resolver use entity selection entity
aggregation by etc etc etc all those
constructors those are the things you
really use and in a sense all those
constructors merely are a setup to do
things I mean it is pretty unfortunate
and it will be hard for debugging right
that what you'll end up with is a giant
and crusted creature that doesn't
evaluate then you hit it with entity
value and then it'll evaluate everything
right now the reason that's a problem is
you know in the usual infinite
evaluation model of symbolic computation
that we have the one nice feature is
that you get to incrementally do things
and you get to see what happened right
whereas what you're proposing here is
something when nothing happens until
everything happens so to speak now you
know you know what I think I can I
actually like this conclusion because I
mean to me and I I would like if I could
decide I would really like to just
deprecated and desist and and so if what
you're saying is that basically if
entity type name cannot resolve to a
base type that entity least fails then
I'm I'm totally fine with that it means
that as soon as you have a more compact
example you just stop relying on at
least mm-hmm which is like it's the
closest we have to dat and suggest fine
I think that's okay as a working
hypothesis but I want to just work
through the thing I just said okay this
problem with debugging did you
understand what I was saying so in other
words right now the way this is set up
it's like you build everything you build
this giant you know castle in the sky
and then suddenly you press the entity
value and the castle sudden resolves and
jumps into life and produces flying
dragons or whatever it's supposed to do
problem is as you're building with
castle you have no idea what's going on
actually I'm dropping a lot with
operator composition and I write broken
stone I don't run into that issue
because I keep adding an operator after
another while doing evaluations again
and again what you're saying okay
so you're saying your style of
programming which now remember in this
case you know what is the resolver for
what you're doing Tony
this is this a sparkle stuff or what
spoke about also general programming so
by I rather keep composing operators and
at the end apply to something or even
past operator around but I can still run
rerun the program after each adding new
operator yeah
well fair enough I mean okay fine all
right look I think we have some kind of
conclusion here
happy with us if so let's let's call it
a day didn't have any complicated this
was a this was a seriously complicated
discussion so I hope people are
listening to this got something out of
it it's a little bit abstract but okay
fair enough
great all right so let's sum so the next
thing we have to do on the on the Stata
base stuff I suppose is you know let's
try and get all the functions renamed in
a reasonable way also assume to remind
we probably should just once again
finalize the naming of single entity
because I think we already discussed
that but I don't I'm not sure if we what
if what do you mean I mean the second
argument that we are using here entity
ID you see above in this example entity
idea of Association did we completely
agree on this form I hope yes but just
to remind what is it you fueled this
example here yeah
there is entity idea of Association yes
so this is how we would like to see
things but what what is that I'm sorry
what is that again that's a canonical
name of this entity this will fail on
that sure because it doesn't resolve to
a string name so I was saying that now
all this business with the complicated
20k IDs is no longer relevant because we
never get single entities of complicated
types out because the entry list was our
only way of getting those well not
exactly the only way because there are
other things like entity association
origins like you can do it with the
third argument of well okay so the
question is listen listen guys we either
have to have a way of making okay so the
thing you
there with entity ID is a resolution of
that which cannot be resolved so to
speak
yes in the way if we are now deprecating
effectively deprecating its to list on
complex tops than yes no I still didn't
today d4 for composite primary keys in
any case but why if you never get single
entities of that type out because if you
have in a database a table with most
people primary is well done you can just
make them into a list it's not that
there's never been to be any confusion
yeah that's the ID thing because we are
not resolving into I mean in a sense
entity ID is a bizarre creature that
basically stores all of its history you
know it packs all its history in some
weird corner because it doesn't want to
admit that it's just not evaluated
actually and I think we don't need it
from the you know in the discussion
we're having right now we don't need it
so just to be clear
sorry I'm
you know what I'd like to do by the way
this entity join thing the word join as
a database join word is a pretty obscure
word and we have another thing that
means join so maybe this is a wake-up
call for us to call that something
different
like entity combination or some such
other thing I don't know what the right
name for it is but let's try to use this
as an excuse to not have to you know
continue the the kind of confusion of
database joining which is a really weird
name
so but let's come back next time
preferably soon and go through what all
of the functions with their noun forms
actually are and how they work and I
think we've now got a way to think about
them where basically they don't resolve
until you entity value them make sense
sounds good to me
okay great clip talk till soon thanks
thanks